EXCLUSIVELY WITH HIS REACTION TO
THE VERDICT IN MOMENTS.
IGNORE THE BRAIN WASHED ZOMBIES
IN THE STREETS.
THE PROSECUTION PUT ON ITS CASE
OF THE EMBARRASSING ITSELF IN
THE PROCESS.
THE DEFENSE PUT ON ITS OWN CASE
WITH MR. RITTENHOUSE CHOOSING TO
WAIVE HIS FIFTH AMENDMENT RIGHT
AND TOOK THE STAND IN HIS OWN
DEFENSE.
THEY SAID ON TELEVISION
RITTENHOUSE WAS A VIGILANTE AND
THEY LIED ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LED TO THE
SHOOTING AND LEBRON JAMES MOCKED
THE DEFENDANT'S EMOTIONAL
TESTIMONY.
THE JURY HEARD IT ALL.
THEY CONSIDERED THE FACTS AND
DELIBERATED FOR A FEW DAYS.
THE JUDGE KEPT THE PROCEEDING
FROM GOING OFF THE RAILS.
IN THE END DESPITE THREATS OF
VIOLENCE, THE JURY DID ITS DUTY.
ACQUITTAL WAS THE ONLY VERDICT
THAT MADE ANY SENSE BASED ON THE
FACTS.
IT WASN'T EVEN CLOSE.
TO THE LEFT THE ACQUITTAL OF
RITTENHOUSE ONLY PROVES WHAT
THEY THOUGHT ABOUT AMERICA ALL
ALONG:
IT'S A HORRIBLE, AWFUL, RACIST
PLACE WHERE LIFE IS
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR.
.
>> AFTER WE SAFER AFTER THIS
VERDICT LETTING KYLE RITTENHOUSE
KILL PEOPLE AND CLAIM
SELF-DEFENSE.
>> WE ARE CELEBRATING POLITICAL
VIOLENCE.
>> A WHITE BOY.
>> THIS IS MAKING SURE THAT
WHITE SUPREMACY CAN TERRORIZE
THE REST OF US.
>> Laura: THESE ARE LIES.
THE WORDS THAT DEMORALIZE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
GIVE UP ON AMERICA.
WHY WORK HARD TO PLAY BY THE
RULES TO GET AHEAD IN
A DISGUSTING RACIST NATION?
WHO WOULD DO THAT.
THESE ARE BITTER AND ANGRY
PEOPLE WHO HATE AMERICA AND ARE
LOOKING FOR CONFIRMATION OF
THEIR ANTI-AMERICAN VIEWS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN COULD HAVE
CALMED DOWN THE CRAZIY --
CRAZIES TODAY.
HE SAID HE AGREES WITH THOSE WHO
ARE ANGRY AND CONCERNED BUT THE
JURY HAS SPOKEN.
HE URGE PEOPLE TO PROTEST
PEACEFULLY.
HIS MESSAGE AND THE WAY IT'S
WORDED IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
THE FACT IS DEMOCRATS GAVE THEIR
APPROVAL TO ALL OF THE DAMAGE
INFLICTED ON AMERICAN CITIES
AFTER GEORGE FLOYD.
MADE EXCUSES FOR CRIMINALS AND
CELEBRATED THE PASSION OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE STREETS.
MAYBE THE WHITE CHIEF OF STAFF
THINKS RACIAL DISCONTENT IS THE
ONLY HOPE OF STOPPING THE RED
WAVE BUT NONE OF IT WILL WORK.
AMERICANS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE RITTENHOUSE
WAS ACQUITTED.
WISCONSIN A STATE THAT BIDEN
WON, WISCONSIN IS NOW RACIST
WITH RACIST JURORS AND JUDGES.
ODD.
NO WONDER DEMOCRATS ARE POISED
TO GET WIPED OUT NEXT YEAR.
IN THE END FACTS DO MATTER.
WHETHER WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
GAS PRICES OR A TRIAL